das ist ein Film über die Macht der
Zentralbanken Zentralbanken haben die
Macht wirtschaftliche politische und
soziale Veränderungen zu
bewirken und so gehen Sie dabei
vor Pearl Harbor 7 dezember
[Musik]
1941 dieser Film basiert auf einem Buch
von Professor Richard
[Musik]
Werner die imperi lang lebe die
kaiserliche Armee
die die Prinzen des
Jen Zentralbanken und die Transformation
der
Wirtschaft
[Musik]
ich gelobe Treue zur Flagge der
Vereinigten Staaten von
[Musik]
Amerika die
Atombombe
[Musik]
wir werden um 9:30 Uhr in Yokohama
ankommen die ausschiffungspriorität
richtet sich nach dem
ausschiffungszeitplan
[Musik]
general Douglas m general Douglas
maarthur traf am 30 August
1945 auf dem marineflugplatz atsugi in
der Nähe von Yokohama
ein als er aus seinem Flugzeug stieg
blieb er oben an der Treppe stehen
steckte eine Hand in die Hüfttasche
spannte den Kiefer um seine
maiskolbenpfeife und betrachtete das
eroberte Land
diese Pose wurde mehrmals wiederholt
damit alle Pressefotografen eine gute
Aufnahme machen
konnten die Demokratie sollte dem
japanischen Volk eingeimpft werden als
hätte es noch nie von etwas anderem
gehört unser Problem liegt im Kopf der
Japaner dies köp Ken
oder schlechte Dinge tun abhängig von
der TE Ideen die in sie hineingelegt
[Musik]
werden Kabuki Stücke in denen loyale
Samurai auftreten wurden verboten oder
stark zensiert ebenso wie Bücher und
Filme über die Bombardierung von
Hiroshima und
Nagasaki überarur und die Erwähnung der
besatzungszensur waren strengstens
untersagt die Kommission befindet sich
verschuldig im Sinne der Anklage und
verurteilt sie zum Tode durch den
Strang Yamashita bedankt sich bei der
Kommission für den fairen Verlauf seines
Prozesses der damalige Premierminister
im Pazifikkrieg general Toyo sagte
während seines Prozesses keiner dieser
Japaner würde es wagen gegen den Willen
des kais
Handel das Kreuzverhör wurde sofort
abgebrochen und eine Woche später
erklärte Toyo pflichtbewusst der Kaiser
habe den Frieden immer geliebt und
gewollt general HID too der die
offizielle Verantwortung für die Führung
des Krieges übernahm und alles tat um
seinen Kaiser zu
entlasten bemerkte später vor dem
ussenat dass sich die Japaner in Bezug
auf die zilisation wie ein 12 Jahre
alter junge
[Musik]
verhielten du interessierst dich für das
Unbekannte das mysteriöse das
Unerklärliche deshalb bist du
hier als der Krieg vorbei war hatten
sich die kreditbücher der Banken
verschlechtert bei den Vermögenswerten
der Banken handelte es sich älich um
Kriegsanleihen und Kredite an zerstörte
Industrien damit war der gesamte
Bankensektor praktisch
bankrott dieses Problem konnte von der
japanischen Zentralbank leicht gelöst
werden sie musste nur die faulen Papiere
des Bankensektors mit neueschaffenen
Reserven aufkaufen und ihnen gutes Geld
für oft wertlose Vermögenswerte
geben die ersten verneure der
Nachkriegszeit wurden von der
amerikanischen Besatzungsmacht
ernannt Araki wurde zum ersten
nachkriegsgouverneur der japanischen
Zentralbank ernannt doch kurz nach
seinem Amtsantritt wurde er von der
Staatsanwaltschaft wegen
Kriegsverbrechen angeklagt und musste
zurücktreten nach einer allgemeinen
Amnestie für mutmaßliche
Kriegsverbrecher die öffentliche Ämter
bekleideten wurde er 191
zum Botschafter in den Vereinigten
Staaten ernannt als er von seinem
Botschafterposten im Jahr 1954 abtrat
wurde Araki erneut zum Gouverneur der
Zentralbank
ernannt nach der Amnestie für
Kriegsverbrecher im Jahr
1951 wurde ein Großteil der japanischen
kriegsbürokraten wieder in ihre
Positionen aus der Kriegszeit versetzt
dazu gehörten Politiker aus der
Kriegszeit und die meisten Bürokraten
des Innenministerium die für die
Gedankenpolizei zuständig gewesen waren
und von denen einige in das
Bildungsministerium
wechselten Japan ist der Schlüssel zum
Schicksal des fernen Ostens noch einmal
zum zweiten Mal während des Vormarsches
der modernen Geschichte haben diese
Worte dringende
Notwendigkeit um Unruhen auf dem Lande
zu verhindern die den Kommunisten in
China in die Hände spielten leiteten die
Amerikaner die Umverteilung von Land von
Großgrundbesitzern an ihre Pächter
ein die kapitalistische Elite Japans die
sogenannte saibatsu wurde wegen ihrer
Unterstützung eines verbrecherischen
Krieges gesäubert und von weiteren
geschäftlichen Aktivitäten
ausgeschlossen im Grunde genommen hat
die US-Besatzung die faschistische
Politik der 30er Jahre die die
reformfaschistischen Bürokraten während
des Krieges nicht umsetzen konnten zu
Ende geführt wie die Landreform und die
saibatu Politik
ja es ist eine sehr seltsame Begegnung
von japanischen kriegsfaschisten und
amerikanischen new
[Musik]
Dealern das Parlament Sitz von Japan
Senat und
Repräsentantenhaus
Japan Studenten und linke Gruppen
tagelang um den gegenseitigen
verteidigungsvertrag mit Amerika zu
verhindern die sozialistischen
Abgeordneten inszenierten einen Aufstand
im Parlament die Polizei vertrieb sie um
die Ordnung
wiederherzustellen der Redner wurde auf
das Podium getragen und rief die Sitzung
in der der Vertrag angenommen wurde zur
Ordnung 7 wurde der ehemalige
Kriegsverbrecher der Klasse A kishinuke
Premierminister von
Japan er war während des Krieges general
tous Minister für Handel und Industrie
gewesen dessen Zuständigkeitsbereich von
Munition bis zur Sklavenarbeit
reichte während Hitlers
kriegswirtschaftsminister in
berlinandauä
war sein japanischer Gegenpart
Ministerpräsident des
Landes obwohl Kishi nach dem Krieg ein
Verfechter der Demokratie wurde hatte er
sich vor und während des Krieges als
Nationalsozialist
bezeichnet mit dem Geld von
verbrechersindndikaten
Industrieunternehmen und CIA
Schmiergeldern baute Kishi die
liberaldemokratische Partei zu einem
mächtigen
App in Japan stammten viele der
wichtigen wirtschaftlichen und
politischen Führer der Nachkriegszeit
aus einer elitären Gruppe von Bürokraten
aus der Kriegszeit die Japan in den
Krieg getrieben
hatten die liberaldemokratische Partei
blieb fast 40 Jahre lang an der
machtkmen auf für diese amerikanischen
Soldaten nach einem Einsatz in Korea
kehren sie zu ihrem Stützpunkt in Japan
zurück wo sie kurz zuvor noch als
Besatzungstruppen stationiert waren und
wie kehren sie zurück wie werden sie von
den Menschen empfangen deren Land sie
besetzen nicht als Oberherren nicht als
Feinde nicht als Männer denen man
misstraut die man fürchtet und denen man
es übel nimmt sondern als
Freunde
[Musik]
in
to im zentralen tokot Stadteil schioda
hatte das Finanzministerium seinen Sitz
von hier aus kontrollierte das
Ministerium die
der japanischen
Wirtschaft das Finanzministerium war das
mächtigste Ministerium und die
Zentralbank musste dem Finanzministerium
Bericht
erstatten Beamte des Finanzministeriums
ernteten eherfurcht und Respekt und
ehemalige Ministerialbeamte erhielten
einflussreiche Posten als Leiter
öffentlicher und privater
[Musik]
Einrichtungen hatte das Ministerium
jedoch keine tatsächliche Kontrolle und
zwar über den Umfang der Kreditschöpfung
und deren Zuteilung über die von der
Bank of Japan der japanischen
Zentralbank entschieden
wurde sie sagten dem Finanzministerium
und der Öffentlichkeit und den
Journalisten wir betreiben Geldpolitik
über den Leitzins und sie ließen das
Finanzministerium über ihre Zinspolitik
bestimmen aber die Herrschaft wurde
nicht über die Zinspolitik erreicht
sondern über die
Geldmenge window guidance ein Verfahren
in dem eine Zentralbank den
Geschäftsbanken Quoten für das
Kreditwachstum und die Kreditvergabe
[Musik]
vorgibt es funktioniert folgendermaßen
man nennt es window guidance die
japanische Zentralbank hat den Banken
einfach gesagt wie viel sie im kommenden
Quartal verleihen müssen und an welchen
Wirtschaftssektor
die japanische Zentralbank erteilte
einzelnen Banken vierteljährlich
Anweisungen über die Höhe der Kredite
und darüber welchen Industriezweigen sie
zuzuordnen waren alle Kredite wurden
nach Sektoren und Teilsektoren
aufgeschlüsselt und die großkreditnehmer
mussten namentlich aufgeführt
werden the Bank of Japan die Zentralbank
konnte entscheiden welche Projekte
gefördert und welche ausgebremst werden
sollten sie diktierte an wen und wofür
die Banken Kredite vergeben
konnten das war das System der
Kriegswirtschaft angepasst an die
Produktion von
Konsumgütern die 5 Millionen Einwohner
Japans genießen heute ein nationales
Einkommen das nur von den Vereinigten
Staaten und den wohlhabend deren
Nationen westuropas übertroffen
wird Kapitalisten aber für die
Bevölkerung hat es eine Menge Reichtum
geschaffen eine sehr gleichmäßige
Einkommens und Vermögensverteilung ein
sehr hohes Wachstum und eine sehr
schnelle Steigerung der Lebensqualität
und des
Lebensstandards in 195 allein im Jahr
1959 wuchs die Wirtschaft um
17%. das System der Kriegswirtschaft
hatte jedoch zerfolge dass ganze
Industriezweige nicht um Gewinne sondern
um Marktanteile konkurrierten
die Unternehmen kämpften bis zum
Bankrott um
Marktanteile dieses Phänomen wurde bald
erkannt und als überhöhter Wettbewerb
bezeichnet die Lösung war die Bildung
von expliziten oder impliziten
Kartellen im Bankensektor fungierte die
als Kontrollmechanismus da die
japanische Zentralbank die Anzahl und
den Wert der von den Banken vergebenen
Kredite vorgeben
konnte infolgedessen änderte sich die
Rangordnung der Banken in der
Nachkriegszeit nie außer nach Fusionen
ein Banker sagte ohne die window
guidance würden wir bis zum Harakiri
miteinander
kämpfen
das Leistungsbilanzdefizit der USA
steigt auf den höchsten Stand seit 9
Jahren das Ausmaß des Anstiegs hat viele
Ökonomen
überrascht während Kartelle den
Wettbewerb innerhalb Japans
kontrollierten gab es solche Grenzen
nicht wenn es um internationale Märkte
ging
japanische Konzerne wurden bald auf
vielen Märkten der Welt
dominant in Amerika wurden formelle
Anhörungen im Kongress abgehalten unter
Titeln wie Produktivität Lektionen für
Amerika lead führende
Wirtschaftstheorien besagen dass nur
freie Märkte zum Erfolg führen können
doch Japan ist innerhalb von Jahrzehnten
zur zweitgrößten volkswi der Welt
aufgestiegen ohne sich nur auf die
unsichtbare Hand der freien Märkte zu
verlassen Japans nachkriegswirtschaft
war eine vollständig mobilisierte
Kriegswirtschaft wobei die Produktion
von Waffen auf Konsumgüter umgestellt
wurde es ist besser für die japanische
Zentralbank nicht aufzufallen und so
still zu sein wie der Wald eines
ländlichen Schreins hisat isim
Gouverneur der japanischen Zentralbank
von 1946 bis
54 da sich die japanische Zentralbank
als Meisterin der freien Märkte
präsentierte galt die window guidance
als Peinlichkeit in offiziellen
Veröffentlichungen wurde sie entweder
nicht erwähnt oder ihre Rolle
heruntergespielt indem die
kreditkontrollen als freiwillig
bezeichnet
wurden min wann immer sich das
Finanzministerium über die
Kreditvergabepolitik der japanischen
Zentralbank erkundigte ließen sich die
Mitarbeiter der japanischen Zentralbank
auf komplexe Diskussionen voller
Fachjargon ein um den Prozess für Lin
undurchschaubar zu
machen in November
im november
1965 kam die erste Serie japanischer
Staatsanleihen auf den Markt von nun an
übten die Politiker wenn Sie mehr Geld
ausgeben wollten nicht mehr Druck auf
die Zentralbank sondern auf das
Finanzministerium aus das Ministerium
würde also letztlich die Aufsicht über
einen immer größer werdenden
staatsschuldenberg
führen
[Musik]
die 1980er Jahre waren eine Ehre der
finanziellen der in der
industrialisierten Welt die meisten
Industrieländer hoben ihre
Beschränkungen für den Kapitalverkehr
auf in Japan forderte tatashi Sasaki ein
ehemaliger Gouverneur der japanischen
Zentralbank einen fünjahresplan für die
Umgestaltung und Liberalisierung der
japanischen
Wirtschaft im Jahr
1986ug beratende Gruppe für die
wirtschaftliche Umstrukturierung unter
der Leitung des ehemaligen Gouverneurs
der japanischen Zentralbank haruo
maikava einen auf 10 Jahre angelegten
wirtschaftsreformplan vor mit dem der
Lebensstandard der Japaner an den des
Westens angeglichen werden
[Musik]
sollte in dem Vorschlag heißt es für
Japan ist jetzt die Zeit gekommen einen
historischen Wandel in seiner
traditionellen Wirtschaftspolitik und
seinem Lebensstil
vorzunehmen ohne diesen Wandel kann es
keine weitere Entwicklung für Japan
geben
Transformation der Bericht l sich wie
ein Wunschzettel der US
handelsunterhändler er begann mit
Forderungen nach einer Verwaltungsreform
und der Abschaffung bürokratischer
Befugnisse das Ziel war die Umgestaltung
der gesamten Politik die Abschaffung des
kriegswirtschaftssystems und die
Einführung einer freien Marktwirtschaft
nach amerikanischem
Vorbild diejenigen Mitglieder der
Beratergruppe die eine abweichende
Meinung äußerten wurden von ihren
Aufgaben
entbunden die
Berte obachter erkannten den radikalen
Charakter des Plans er schien viel zu
ehrgeizig erfte eine umfassende
Revolution aller Teile des japanischen
wirtschaftlichen politischen und
sozialen
[Musik]
Systems obwohl der Bericht klar
formulierte was gewollt war Schwieger
sich peinlich darüber aus wie diese
Ziele erreicht werden sollten
der einzige Hinweis der im Bericht
versteckt war lautete bei der Umsetzung
dieser Empfehlungen kommt der Steuer und
Geldpolitik eine wichtige Rolle
[Musik]
zu die japanische Zentralbank hat immer
gesagt dass das japanische System
abgeschafft werden sollte es sollte
einfach komplett abgeschafft werden und
der Kapitalismus nach amerikanischem
Vorbild sollte eingeführt werden ob sie
damit einverstanden sind oder nicht ist
eine ganz andere Frage aber die
Zentralbank ist auf jeden Fall der
Meinung dass es abgeschafft werden
sollte die nächste Frage ist nun wie man
das anstellen soll das Finanzministerium
hat die meiste Zeit der Nachkriegszeit
rechtlich die Kontrolle gehabt wir haben
eingefahrene bürokratische Strukturen
Politiker und all diese Kartelle und so
weiter das war das alte System nun lhrt
die Geschichte dass sich ein System nur
dann grundlegend ändert wenn es eine
Krise
gibt
die Kommission schlug vor dass die
Geldpolitik zur Förderung einer
historischen Krise eingesetzt werden
sollte die groß genug ist um die
Interessen des Finanzministeriums der
Politiker und der japanischen
Unternehmen zu
überwinden in jedem System gibt es
Gruppen die davon profitieren und daher
nicht den Wunsch haben es zu ändern es
gibt wahrscheinlich kein Land auf der
Welt das sein wirtschaftliches soziales
und politisches System ohne eine Krise
in nennenswerter Weise verändert
hat es ist die Krise die die Bürger und
Interessensgruppen von der Notwendigkeit
eines Wandels
überzeugt nun wie kann man das erreichen
man braucht eine Krise und der beste Weg
sie zu erzeugen ist eine Blase denn so
hält eine niemand
[Musik]
auf
jap die japanische Zentralbank begann
die Quoten für die Vergabe von
schaufensterkrediten deutlich zu erhöhen
in den späten 1980er Jahren lagen die
durchschnittlichen jährlichen
kreditwachstumsquoten bei fast 15% ein
städtischer Banker bemerkte später
während der Spekulationsblase wollten
wir nur eine bestimmte Anzahl von
Krediten erhöhen aber die japanische
Zentralbank wollte dass wir mehr
schaffen
[Musik]
junge Leute in ihren 20ern und 30ern
konnten sich auch mit bescheidenen
Gehältern zweit und drittwohnungen
kaufen der kreditbom führte nicht nur zu
einem immobilienbom sondern auch zu
einem Boom auf dem
aktienmarkt5 und
1989 stiegen die Aktien um
240% und die Grundstückspreise um 245%
[Musik]
Ende der 80er Jahre war der Wert des
Gartens der den Kaiserpalast im Zentrum
Tokios umgibt so viel wert wie der
gesamte Staat
Kalifornien
[Musik]
obwohl Japan nur 126 der Größe der
Vereinigten Staaten hat wurde sein Grund
und Boden mit dem Vierfachen des Wertes
der Vereinigten Staaten
[Musik]
bewertet der Marktwert eines einzigen
der 23 Bezirke von tok der Zentrale
Bezirk shioda überstiegt den Wert von
ganz Kanada
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler die darauf
trainiert sind an Marktergebnisse zu
glauben versuchten die hohen
Grundstückspreise zu rechtfertigen
einige glaubten dass die
grundstücksknappheit der Grund
sei in Tokos noblelen Geschäftsvierteln
entstanden glänzende neue
Firmenzentralen der Arbeitsmarkt boomte
so sehr dass ein ernsthafter Mangel an
Arbeitskräften befürchtet
[Musik]
wurde die Unternehmen begannen Studenten
im letzten Studienjahr zu teuren Reisen
in Ferienorte einzuladen um sie zu einer
Anstellung zu
bewegen die Politiker liebten es das
Finanzministerium liebte es die
Steuereinnahmen stiegen die Unternehmen
liebten es alles war wunderbar in der
buabelera jeder Tag war wie ein Fest wie
Mädchen wurden ausgeführt und alles
wurde immer von den Jungs und den Chef
bezahlt niemand hat öffentliche
Verkehrsmittel benutzt um nach Hause zu
kommen wir haben immer ein Taxi
[Musik]
genommen angesichts des unaufhaltsamen
Anstiegs der Vermögens und Aktienkurse
konnten selbst traditionelle Hersteller
der Versuchung nicht widerstehen sich an
den Märkten zu versuchen bald bauten sie
ihre Finanz und Treasury Abteilungen aus
um die Spekulationen selbst in die Hand
zu nehmen
diese Hedgefonds der Unternehmen bekannt
als ctec nutzten gelienes Geld um mit
Immobilien und Aktien zu
spekulieren der Wahnsinn nahm solche
Ausmaße an dass viele führende
Hersteller wie z.B der Autohersteller
Nissan mehr Geld mit spekulativen
Investitionen als mit der Produktion von
Autos verdienten es wurden buchstäblich
Tausende von Artikeln über das neue
japanische Wirtschaftswunder
geschrieben
viele Wirtschaftswissenschaftler gaben
an dass die hohe und steigende
Produktivität die beeindruckende
Leistung der japanischen Wirtschaft
erklärt Bücher über japanische
Managementtechniken wurden zu
internationalen Bestsellern westliche
Geschäftsleute lasen Traktate aus dem 17
Jahrhundert über
samuristrategien
[Musik]
in reality in Wirklichkeit hatte Japans
herausragende Leistung in den 1980er
Jahren wenig mit Managementtechniken zu
tun anstatt die Kreditvergabe zu
begrenzen und zu steuern wurde die
schaufensterpolitik dazu genutzt eine
riesige Blase zu
erzeugen ich habe Nachforschungen
angestellt und Beamte der japanischen
Zentralbank und Banker beide Seiten auf
Tonband befragt das Ergebnis war dass
die japanische Zentralbank ihre
informelle Beratung fortsetzte
tatsächlich war es die japanische
Zentralbank die die Banken dazu zwang
ihre Kreditvergabe so stark zu
erhöhen
Japan die japanische Zentralbank wusste
dass die einzige Möglichkeit für die
Banken ihre kreditquoten zu erfüllen
darin bestand die unproduktive
Kreditvergabe auszuweiten mit den Worten
eines Bankangestellten wenn es keine
Nachfrage nach Krediten von risikoarmen
Kreditnehmern gibt und wir die Quote
ausschöpfen wollen wird das Risiko noch
größer ein anderer bankker wird mit den
Worten zitiert dass ein Nebeneffekt der
Regel der window guidance bei der
Kreditvergabe darin bestand dass die
Banken die Kreditvergabe auch dann
erhöhten wenn es keine Kreditnachfrage
gab
like all bubbles wie alle Blasen wurde
auch die japanische Blase einfach durch
die rasche Geldschöpfung des
Bankensystems
angeheizt zwischen 1986 und
1989 leitete toshihik Fukui die
bankenabteilung der japanischen
Zentralbank die für die Quoten für die
window guidance
als fui von einem Journalisten gefragt
wurde die Kreditaufnahmen im schnell zu
haben sie nicht die Absicht den han bei
den Bankkrediten zuzudrehen antwortete
er da die konsequente Politik der
geldpolitischen Lockerung fortgesetzt
wird würde eine quantitative Kontrolle
der Bankkredite einen Widerspruch in
sich darstellen daher haben wir nicht
die Absicht eine quantitative Straffung
durchzuführen
da die strukturelle Anpassung der
Wirtschaft schon seit geraumer Zeit
andauert werden die internationalen
Ungleichgewichte angegangen die
Geldpolitik unterstützt dies sodass wir
die Verantwortung haben die lockere
Geldpolitik so lange wie möglich
fortzusetzen daher ist es nur natürlich
dass die Bankkredite ausgeweitet
werden die Banken so viel Geld verlienen
weil sie durch die Anweisung der
japanischen Zentralbank dazu gezwungen
wurden normalerweise wählen die Banken
ihre Kunden aus einer großen Anzahl von
kreditantragsstellern aus und lehnen
einen erheblichen Prozentsatz
ab doch ab 1987 hatte sich das Blatt
gewend
es waren die ber die aggressiv und
potenzielle Kunden waren es gibt viele
Anekdoten darüber wie die Banken Kredite
zu günstigen Zinssätzen anboten und
Kunden wie Straßenhändler umworben
haben die Banken ermutigten die Menschen
sich Geld zu leihen wenn z.B ein frisch
verheiratetes Paar ein Haus kaufen
wollte boten ihnen die Banken den
doppelten Betrag den sie
verlangten
die bankker schätzten den
Grundstückswert zunehmend überhöht ein
sodass das tatsächliche Verhältnis von
Grundstückswert zu Kredit oft auf 300%
oder mehr
Anstieg für die Öffentlichkeit Verdi ein
seltsames Phänomen die Leute nannten es
bald geldüberschuss nur
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler Analysten und
diejenigen die an den Finanzmärkten oder
für Immobilien Firmen arbeiten wussten
es
besser sie lehnten solche
vereinfachenden Analysen ab sie
behaupteten dass der Anstieg der
Grundstückspreise weitaus kompliziertere
Gründe hätte als nur einen
geldüberschuss gewöhnliche Menschen
verstanden einfach nicht die Feinheiten
der modernen
finanztechnologie
wenn ein Land zu viel Geld schafft
fließt ein Teil dieses Geldes in Form
von Investitionen ins Ausland ab in den
80er Jahren vervielfachten sich die
japanischen Kapitalströme von einem
Nettozufluss von mehr als 2 Milliarden
Dollar im Jahr 1980 auf einen Abfluss
von 132
im Jahr
1986 Vermögenswerte darunter
Kunstgegenstände und andere
Wertgegenstände in der ganzen Welt
wurden zum Ziel japanischer Käufer es
gab hochkarätige Käufe wie das
Rockefeller Center Columbia Pictures und
den peble Beach
golfc
und schrebe 75% aller 1986 versteigerten
usstaatsanleihen aber es ist nicht
einfach für ein Land einfach Geld zu
drucken und dann auf eine einkaufstur
durch die Welt zu gehen Japan war dazu
in der Lage weil die Märkte seine
Währung nicht
abwertetener
festgelegt wenn die traditionellen
Indikatoren auf die die Devisenhändler
achten die übermäßige Geldschöpfung in
den betreffenden Land nicht anzeigen
kann es funktionieren große Geldmengen
zu schaffen und zu versuchen sie in
ausländische Währung
umzutauschen Japan Japan hatte denselben
Trick angewandt wie die Vereinigten
Staaten in den 1950er und 1960er Jahren
als die US-Banken exzessiv Dollars
schufen die amerikanischen Unternehmen
nutzten dieses heiße Geld um europäische
Unternehmen
aufzukaufen während die Vereinigten
Staaten durch den Goldstandard des
Dollars gedeckt waren bestand Japans
Deckung in einem erheblichen
Handelsüberschuss ein nicht BIP
basierter Kredit ein Kredit der nicht
für die Produktion von Waren oder
Dienstleistungen verwendet
wird ein frühwahnindikator für die
Entstehung eines systemischen Risikos im
Bankensystem ist das Verhältnis von
Krediten für nicht BIP basierte
Transaktionen zu den
gesamtkrediten in den meisten Ländern
die anschließend von einer Bankenkrise
heimgesucht werden steigt dieses
Verhältnis deutlich
an
es war derselbe Prozess der die
Hypothekenkredite und den Boom der
Immobilienpreise in den Vereinigten
Staaten und im Vereinigten Königreich in
den 1980er und 2000er Jahren anheizte
derselbe Prozess führte auch zu den
Goldenen 20ern in den 1920er Jahren
vergaben die Banken in den USA Kredite
mit Aktien als Sicherheiten das Prinzip
bleibt dasselbe da jede Bank den
Aktienkurs als gegeben ansah schuf sie
neues
Geld je mehr Geld auf dem Aktienmarkt
war desto mehr mussten die Aktienkurse
steigen jede Bank hielt es für sicher
einen bestimmten Prozentsatz des
aktienwerts als Sicherheit zu
akzeptieren aber die Aktionen aller
Banken zusammen trieben den Gesamtmarkt
in die
Höhe in Japan stieg das gesamte
Grundvermögen des privaten Sektors von ,
Billionen Yen im Jahr
1969 auf 2000 Billionen Yen im Jahr
1989 auf seiner ersten Pressekonferenz
als 26 Gouverneur der japanischen
Zentralbank im Jahr
1989 sagte yasushi mieno da die lockere
Geldpolitik das Problem des Anstiegs der
Grundstückspreise verursacht habe werde
die Kreditvergabe im Zusammenhang mit
Immobilien nun eingeschränkt
er sah sich um sah die Blase die
steigenden Vermögenspreise die immer
größer werdende Kluft zwischen Arm und
Reich das müssen wir stoppen sein Name
war meno und er war ein Held in der
Presse weil er gegen diese dumme
Geldpolitik kämpfte tatsache ist jedoch
dass er in der Zeit der Blase
stellvertretender Gouverneur und für die
Entstehung der Blase verantwortlich
war
[Musik]
plötzlich stiegen die Grundstücks und
Vermögenspreise nicht mehr allein im
Jahr 1990 brach der Aktienmarkt um 32%
ein
[Musik]
dann im Juli 1991 wurde die window
guidance abgeschafft dies kam für die
Verantwortlichen der japanischen
Zentralbank selbst überraschend die
Bänker waren nahe zuu hilflos sie
beklagten sich darüber dass sie nicht
mehr wussten wie sie ihre
kreditvergabepläne erstellen sollten
wenn in der Vergangenheit eine bestimmte
Filiale sagte dass sie gerne mehr
Kredite vergeben würde antworteten sie
dass die Quote für die window GUID
ausgeschöpft
sei jetzt konnten sie das nicht mehr
[Musik]
tun als die Banken erkannten dass der
Großteil der 99 Billionen Yen an
buabbelkrediten wahrscheinlich scheitern
würde wurden sie so ängstlich dass sie
nicht nur die Kreditvergabe an
Spekulanten einstellten sondern auch die
Kreditvergabe an alle
anderen
nun es stehen düstere Weihnachten für
Japan bevor die Börse sank am Montag auf
den niedrigsten Stand seit über Z Jahren
der Zusammenbruch eines der größten
Lebensmittelhändler Japans in der
vergangenen Woche war der neun eines
börsennotierten Unternehmens in diesem
[Musik]
Jahr mehr als 5 Millionen Japaner
verloren ihre Arbeit und fanden keine
andere
beschäftigungelstmord wur Todesursache
bei Männern im Alter zwischen 20 und 44
[Musik]
Jahren die Zeitungen berichteten fast
täglich über Menschen die sich erhäten
oder
[Musik]
verschwandenwischen und fiel der
Aktienmarkt um 80% die Grundstückspreise
in den Großstädten fielen um bis zu
84%. einige Ökonomen Schienen
erleichtert zu
sein der Abschwung war ein Beweis dafür
dass Japans Wirtschaftssystem doch nicht
so erfolgreich
war unterdessen sagte der Gouverneur der
japanischen Zentralbank yasushieno dass
sich dank dieser Rezession jeder der
Notwendigkeit einer wirtschaftlichen
Umgestaltung bewusst wird economic
[Musik]
Transformation das Finanzministerium das
die Zinssätze für das wichtigste
politische Instrument hielt übte Druck
auf die Zentralbank aus die Zinssätze zu
senken bis der offizielle Zinssatz 0,1%
erreichte die meisten
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler sagten eine
wirtschaftliche Erholung
[Musik]
voraus but despite doch trotz der
häufigen Behauptungen in der
Finanzpresse und von den Zentralbanken
dass niedrigere Zinsen das Wachstum
ankurbeln und höhere Zinsen das Wachstum
bremsen gibt es keine empirischen Belege
für diesen
Zusammenhang
[Musik]
p japanische und amerikanische
Geschäftsleute treffen sich hier mit
einem pldoyer der japanischen
Unternehmen für einen niedrigeren Yen
nur 6% der japanischen Exporteure können
bei einem Dollarkurs von weniger als 100
Yen Gewinne erzielen im Durchschnitt
müssen Sie die amerikanische Währung auf
über 117 Yen anheben um die
Gewinnschwelle zu
erreichen das Finanzministerium Bart die
Zentralbank große Mengen an Yen zu
verkaufen und US-Dollar zu kaufen damit
der Wechselkurs des Jen sinken und die
Exporte steigen
würden wir alle wissen dass die beiden
das Finanzministerium und die
Zentralbank nicht gut miteinander
auskommen und was diesen Monat wieder
passiert ist ist dass die Zentralbank
ihre eigenen Interventionen sterilisiert
hat um genau zu sein die Interventionen
die vom Finanzministerium angeord
das Finanzministerium weist die
japanische Zentralbank an US
Staatsanleihen im Wert von etwa 20
Milliarden zu kaufen doch die japanische
Zentralbank sterilisiert dies das heißt
sie entzieht der Wirtschaft Geld um
diesen Kauf zu finanzieren die meisten
Forscher sind sich einig dass
sterilisierte
Devisenmarktinterventionen nicht
funktionieren die Zentralbank
sterilisiert erneut deshalb funktioniert
es nicht deshalb ist der Jen stark
geblieben
[Musik]
eine Zentralbank kann Geld aus der
Wirtschaft abziehen indem sie ihre
Vermögenswerte verkauft genauso wie sie
der Wirtschaft Geld zuführen kann indem
sie Vermögenswerte
kauft wenn Zentralbanken Vermögenswerte
kaufen und verkaufen erhöhen oder
verräern sie die in der Wirtschaft
zirkulierende
Geldmenge Beamten der japanischen
Zentralbank ignorierten dies und
behaupteten stattdessen dass dieser
Strukturwandel oder diese Reform
kurzfristig deflationäre Kräfte erzeugen
kann aber nach einer Weile eine viel
effizientere Wirtschaft hervorbringen
wird independent observice unabhängige
Beobachter meinten die Binnennachfrage
müsse durch staatliche Ausgaben
angekurbelt werden dann würde auch die
Kredit Nachfrage
steigen ein Jahrzehnt lang befolgte die
Regierung diesen Rat und steigerte die
Staatsverschuldung auf ein historisches
Niveau zwischen
1992 und 2002 wurden 146 Billionen Yen
ausgegeben Richard Werner ist
Chefvolkswirt bei jord fling securrities
in tok er teilt uns jetzt seine
Ansichten zur Entwicklung der Wirtschaft
mit die Regierung gab mit der rechten
Hand Geld aus indem sie der Wirtschaft
Geld zuführte aber die Mittelbeschaffung
erfolgte über den Anleihemarkt und
deshalb entnahm sie mit der linken Hand
dasselbe Geld aus der Wirtschaft es gab
keinen Anstieg der
gesamtkaufkraft bis 2011 würde Japans
Staatsverschuldung 230% des BIP
erreichen die höchste der
Welt
[Musik]
dem Finanzministerium gingen die
Möglichkeiten aus Beobachter begannen
das Ministerium für die Rezession
verantwortlich zu machen und begannen
auf die Stimmen zu hören die behaupteten
die Rezession sei auf das japanische
Wirtschaftssystem
zurückzuführen aber wie schwierig wäre
es gewesen die Probleme der faulen
Kredite im Bankensektor und der
Deflation zu lösen es stellte sich
heraus dass dies gar nicht so schwierig
gewesen wäre das Finanzsystem ist immer
ein Teufelskreis es gibt kein
Kreditwachstum also gibt es kein
Wirtschaftswachstum also gibt es kein
Wirtschaftswachstum nun es gibt eine
Sache die dieses zirkuläre Argument
durchbrechen kann und das ist die
Zentralbank die Aufgabe der Zentralbank
in dieser Situation ist es Geld zu
drucken was wir jetzt brauchen sind
radikalere Maßnahmen und es gibt ige
schmerzhafte aber es gibt auch
schmerzlose die Zentralbank könnte z.B
einfach alle faulen Schulden zum
Nennwert aufkaufen Japan hätte dann die
stärksten Banken der
Welt um den Bankensektor zu retten kann
eine Zentralbank die faulen
finanzaktivver der Banken mit
neugeschaffenem Geld aufkaufen und ihnen
den Nennwert für die aktiv geben die auf
deutlich weniger wert sind so hat es die
japanische Zentralbank nach dem Krieg
getan
alternativ könnte Geld an die Banken
transferiert werden indem man ihnen
mitteilt große Gewinne zu erzielen eine
Möglichkeit dies zu erreichen besteht
darin dass die Zentralbank einen Markt
in die Enge treibt und so eine miniblase
in einem bestimmten Markt schafft in den
die Banken stark investieren was ihnen
große Gewinne
beschert ist einea gängige meode der
Zentralbanken um ihren Bankensystemen zu
helfen andere Vorschläge beinhalten
Maßnahmen zur Einführung von Null
risikokreditnehmern bei Banken oder die
Einführung von Änderungen in der
Rechnungslegung die ihre Bilanzen
verbessern in Japan in Japan
argumentierten die Behörden und die
Zentralbank wie fast zwei Jahrzehnte
später auch die westlichen Mächte dass
der Steuer zahler die Rechnung bezahlen
[Musik]
sollte wie sie sich vielleicht erinnern
hat die Regierung im März letzten Jahres
etwa 15 großen japanischen
Finanzinstituten eine große Summe Geld
zugeführt und wir waren eines von ihnen
das hat uns geholfen faule Kredite
abzuschreiben und unsere Kapitalbasis zu
stärken damit wir bereit sind Kredite zu
vergeben
Steuergelder wurden zur
Rekapitalisierung von Banken verwendet
es gibt jedoch keine Beweise dafür dass
die Steuerzahler für die Probleme der
Banken verantwortlich waren daher haben
solche Maßnahmen wahrscheinlich ein
moralisches Risiko
geschaffen die Geldmenge wird durch den
Nettozuwachs der Geldschöpfung der
Banken und derentral timmt wenn das
moralische Risiko vorschreibt dass der
Bankensektor nicht gerettet werden
sollte können Deflation und Rezession
von der Zentralbank immer noch vermieden
werden zu diesem Zweck kann die
Zentralbank die Geldmenge
erhöhen eine Zentralbank kann die
Geldmenge in einer Volkswirtschaft
jederzeit und unbegrenzt erhöhen indem
sie einfach Vermögenswerte vom privaten
Sektor kauft und mit neueschaffenen
Krediten bezahlt die Zentralbank hätte
z.B Immobilien kaufen und in öffentliche
Parks umwandeln
können und hier besteht die Möglichkeit
drei Probleme auf einen Schlag zu lösen
die Wirtschaft braucht Geldschöpfung die
Banken müssen ihre faulen Kredite
loswerden und der Immobiliensektor
braucht einige Transaktionen was man tun
kann ist die Zentralbank Geld drucken zu
lassen den Banken das Land abzukaufen es
in Parks umzuwandeln und damit auch ein
weiteres Problem zu lösen die
Lebensqualität in
Japan
selbst wenn die Zentralbank diese Parks
später zu einem Bruchteil der Kosten
verkauft hätte hätte sie immer noch Geld
verdient weil es eine Zentralbank nichts
kostet das Geld überhaupt erst zu
schaffen eine weitere Möglichkeit Geld
in die Wirtschaft zu pumpen ist die
quantitative
Lockerung trotz dieserögitenigerte sich
die japanische zentralb
zuedemit zu ergreifen die die Krise
hätten lösen
können als ich
1992 1993 als Gastwissenschaftler bei
der japanischen Zentralbank war war ich
davon überzeugt dass diese Rezession
wirklich schlimm werden würde also
fragte ich jeden Mitarbeiter der
japanischen Zentralbank der mit mir
sprechen wollte warum sie nicht mehr
Geld drucken ich traf eine Person die
sehr offen darüber sprach und sie sagte
Richard natürlich hätten wir mehr Geld
drucken können wir hätten einen
Aufschwung herbehren können aber dann
hätte sich nichts geändert die
Wirtschaftsstruktur hätte sich nicht
verändert damals war ich noch nicht
bereit zu glauben dass die Zentralbank
die Rezession ernsthaft in die Länge zog
um strukturelle Veränderungen zu
erreichen die mir ein wenig zu wild
erschienen Finanzminister masayuroiokava
hat sich an die Zentralbank gewandt und
sie gebeten die Deflation zu stoppen
oder zumindest zu
bekämpfen die Zentralbank widersetzte
sich konquent auffungen
finanministers und des Premierministers
mehr Geld zu drucken um die Wirtschaft
anzukurbeln und die lange Rezession zu
beenden zeitweise reduzierte die
japanische Zentralbank sogar aktiv die
in der Wirtschaft zirkulierende
Geldmenge was die Rezession noch
[Musik]
verschlimmerte die Argumente der
japanischen Zentralbank waren immer die
gleichen nämlich die Sch Struktur Japans
liegt C Mitarbeiter der Zentralbank
argumentierten sogar dass eine
erhebliche geldpolitische Lockerung
Schaden anrichten könnte indem sie eine
weitere Verzögerung des Fortschritts der
strukturellen Anpassung
bewirke die früheren japanischen Führer
der Nachkriegszeit wussten dass sie eine
Kriegswirtschaft betrieben aber sie aus
politischen Gründen nicht darüber
sprechen die propagandabotschaft des
Kalten Krieges lautete dass das Japan
der Nachkriegszeit ein politisches und
wirtschaftliches System nach
amerikanischem Vorbild übernommen
hatte da sie nicht bereit waren die
Wahrheit zu sagen nahmen die frühen
nachkriegsführer ihr intimes Wissen über
die Ursprünge von Japans
Wirtschaftswunder mit ins Grab in den
1980er und 1990er Jahren herrschte eine
Generation von Bürokrat
die den wren Charakter und Zweck der
Wirtschaft ihres Landes nicht
[Musik]
verstanden eine ganze Generation
japanischer Wirtschaftswissenschaftler
wurde in die Vereinigten Staaten
geschickt um dort einen Doktortitel und
einen MBA Abschluss in
Wirtschaftswissenschaften nach
amerikanischem Vorbild zu
erwerben neoklassis wirtsaswissensaft
d und Wirtschaftssystem gibt nämlich
uneingeschränkte freie Märkte in denen
Aktionäre und zentralbänker das Sagen
haben haben viele japanische
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler schnell die
Argumente der US-amerikanischen
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler
[Musik]
nachgeplappert die USA und Japan haben
am Dienstag zweitägige Gespräche über
versicherungsregulier
die Deregulierung des primärsektors ist
notwendig um die festgefahrenen
Interessen der großen
Versicherungsgesellschaften sowohl der
Lebens als auch Sachversicherer und die
Bürokratie des Finanzministeriums zu
überwinden sie müssen vor dem 15
Dezember eine Einigung erzielen denn
nach diesem Datum haben die USA mit
Handelssanktionen gedroht ein wichtiger
Schritt den Analysten erwarten ist die
Verbriefung von Immobilien aber wird das
Paket ausreichen Z im Gespräch mit
Richard Werner um eine sinnvolle
Verbriefung zu erreichen brauchen wir
eine Deregulierung und das ist bereits
die Antwort auf Ihre Frage um eine
Deregulierung zu erreichen müssen sie
die Macht des Finanzministeriums
beschneiden und offensichtlich hat sich
das Ministerium dem
widersetzt in den 1980er Jahren wurden
Personen die sich mit einer Visitenkarte
des renommierten Finanzministeriums
vorstellen konnten verehrt und
respektiert doch Mitte der 1990er Jahre
hatte sich die Einstellung geändert und
für die meisten Beobachter gab es kaum
noch Zweifel daran dass das
Finanzministerium die Rezession
verursacht
hatte vor den Toren des Ministeriums kam
es häufig zu Demonstrationen von Bürgern
die über die Handlungen der Bürokraten
empört
waren in ear 199 Anfang 1998 führte die
Staatsanwaltschaft zum ersten Mal eine
Ria im mächtigsten japanischen
Ministerium
durch sowohl die Banken als auch ihre
Aufsichtsbehörden wurden für ihr
Vorgehen heftig kritisiert die Skandale
warfen ein Schlaglicht auf einige der
informellen Verbindungen die zwischen
Beamten des Finanzministeriums und
Bänkern bestanden viele Bankangestellte
und sogar einige Ministerialbeamte
wurden verhaftet und ins Gefängnis
gesteckt und mehrere begingen
Selbstmord Central Bank wi der
Zentralbanker masassaaki shirakava
erklärt hatte es ist nicht einfach den
institutionellen Rahmen zu ändern und
strukturelle Reformen zu fördern da dies
notwendigerweise die Interessen aller
Beteiligten Wirtschaftsakteure
berührt Yutaka yamaguci Yutaka yamagucci
ein stellvertretender Gouverneur der
japanischen Zentralbank sagte dass die
Zentralbank vor dem großen Dilemma steht
dass die Lockerung der eldpitik zu einer
Abschwächung der unmittelbaren Risiken
führen würde was wiederum eine
Verzögerung der endgültigen Lösungen zur
Folge
hätte ab Mitte der9er Jahren die
Regierung einte des Finanzministeriums
abzubauen die Zentralbank hingegen
konnte ihren Einfluss erheblich
ausbauen sie haben erst kürzlich
geschrieben sie haben keinen Zweifel
daran dass die Zentralbank die
japanische Zentralbank vom
Finanzministerium losgelöst und
unabhängig werden wird sodass sie mit
anderen Zentralbanken gleichgestellt
wird warum sind Sie so
sicher im Grunde genommen hat das
Finanzministerium das zumindest die
Zentralbank rechtlich kontrollierte jede
glaub or das Finanzministerium wird für
die Entstehung der Blase für die lange
Rezession und für viele andere Probleme
die wir in letzter Zeit in Japan hatten
verantwortlich gemacht die japanische
Zentralbank hgegen stand nicht im
Rampenlicht der öffentlichen Kritik und
nutzt dies nun um zu sagen nun das
Finanzministerium war schlecht wir
brauchen jetzt
Unabhängigkeit Richard vielen Dank ich
habe mit Richard Werner gesprochen dem
Chefvolkswirt von fling secur in
Tokio kurz nach seinem ausschalten aus
dem Amt des Gouverneurs der japanischen
Zentralbank im Jahr
1994 begann mieno eine Kampagne mit
Reden vor verschiedenen Verbänden und
Interessensgruppen er setzte sich für
eine Änderung des Gesetzes über die
Zentralbank
ein seine Argumentation bestand darin
auf subtile Weise anzudeuten dass das
Finanzministerium die japanische
Zentralbank zu einer falschen Politik
gedrängt hatte um solche Probleme in
Zukunft zu vermeiden müsse der
japanischen Zentralbank volle rechtliche
Unabhängigkeit gewährt
werden die Unabhängigkeit der
Zentralbanken so mieno entspreche der
menschlichen Weisheit die sich in der
Geschichte entwickelt habe im Jahr 1998
wurde die Geldpolitik in die Hände der
nun unabhängigen japanischen Zentralbank
gelegt
sie sagen also dass sowohl Politiker als
auch Ökonomen mehr Druck auf die
japanische Zentralbank ausüben sollten
mehr Geld zu schaffen aber viele
Kritiker werden sagen dass das ein
Eingriff in die Unabhängigkeit der
Zentralbank ist was halten Sie
davon das ist genau richtig das ist ein
Eingriff in die Unabhängigkeit der
Zentralbanken und das ist genau das was
wir
brauchen
[Musik]
die zahlreichen Skandale die auf das
Platzen der Blase folgten brachten 1995
auch das System der
Einparteienherrschaft der
liberaldemokratischen Partei zu fallall
in im alten System konkurrierten die
Politiker nicht miteinander indem sie
unterschiedliche politikstile
vorschlugen die Politik wurde von den
Bürokraten gemacht und die Politiker
konzentrierten sich lediglich darauf
lokale Wählerschaften mit öffentlichen
Bauprojekten zu
beschwichtigen in oktober 1997 im
Oktober 1997 gingen zum ersten Mal in
der Nachkriegsgeschichte alle
politischen Initiativen zur Ankurbelung
der Wirtschaft von Politikern und nicht
von Bürokraten
aus in 200 Anfang 2001 wurde dann ein
neuer typpolitiker an die Macht
gebracht
iro kuisumi wurde Premierminister in
Bezug auf seine Popularität und seine
Politik wird er oft mit Margaret
Thatcher und Ronald Dragon verglichen
seine Botschaft war einfach kein
Aufschwung ohne
[Musik]
Strukturreformen
auf dem Genfer Gipfel im Juli 2001 sagte
er manche sagen der Aufschwung kommt
zuerst ohne Reformen aber sobald sich
die Wirtschaft erholt schwindet der
Wille zu Reformen deshalb werde ich nach
den Wahlen an dem Plan festhalten dass
es ohne Strukturreformen kein Wachstum
geben
wird im Laufe des Jahres 2001 wurde die
Botschaft dass es ohne Strukturreformen
gib fast täglich über die
Fernsehbildschirme der Nation
verbreitet die Länder des G7 Gipfels
üben Druck auf Japan aus
Strukturreformen durchzuführen in Korea
gab es Unruhen aber dann beschloss die
Regierung große Konglomerate zu
zerschlagen jetzt erholt sich die
Wirtschaft des Landes nun ist es an der
Zeit dass Japan Strukturreformen
[Musik]
durchführt jetzt glaubt jeder dass wir
strukturelle Veränderungen brauchen dass
wir den Kapitalismus japanischer Prägung
abschaffen müssen um einen Aufschwung zu
erreichen es scheint dass wir alles
ausprobiert haben und nichts hat
funktioniert also muss das japanische
Wirtschaftssystem schuld sein daher
sollten wir es besser
[Musik]
loswerden
Japan Japan stellte sein
Wirtschaftssystem auf eine
Marktwirtschaft nach amerikanischem
Vorbild um und das bedeutete auch dass
das Zentrum der Wirtschaft von den
Banken auf die Aktienmärkte verlagert
wurde um Einleger dazu zu bewegen ihr
Geld von den Banken abzuziehen und in
den riskanten Aktienmarkt zu investieren
hoben die Reformer die Garantie für alle
Bankeinlagen auf und schufen
gleichzeitig steuerliche Anreize für
aktieninvestitionen mit der Ausbreitung
des shareholderkapitalismus nach
amerikanischem Vorbild stiegen die
Arbeitslosigkeit die Einkommens und
vermögensunterschiede sowie Selbstmorde
und Gewaltverbrechen erheblich
an im Jahr 2002 verstärkte die
japanische Zentralbank dann ihre
Bemühungen die Bankbilanzen zu
verschlechtern und die Banken zu zwingen
ihre Kreditnehmer Zwang zu vollstrecken
bis dahin hatte sich Haku janagisava
Minister für
Finanzdienstleistungen gegen den von der
japanischen Zentralbank inspirierten
Vorschlag gewährt den Banken Steuergeld
dazu zuführen sie faktisch zu
verstaatlichen ihre Verwaltung zu
übernehmen und diese Macht zu nutzen um
Kredite von Unternehmen einzufordern was
zu zahlreichen Insolvenzen von
Großunternehmen
führte mranwa janagisawa wurde daraufhin
vom Premierminister entlassen und durch
hese takenaka ersetzt takenaka war ein
Befürworter des Plans der japanischen
Zentralbank die Zahl der
Zwangsvollstreckungen von Kreditnehmern
zu erhöhen
Minister takenaka versuchte eine Politik
umzusetzen die die Bilanzen der Banken
drastisch schwächte um sie
verstaatlichen zu
können
takaka takaka ernannte eine Taskforce
zur Überwachung der bankenpolitik der
zwei ehemalige Mitarbeiter der
japanischen Zentralbank angehörten einer
von ihnen Takeshi Kimura forderte sofort
die Einführung von Änderungen in der
Rechnungslegung die die Bilanzen der
Banken verschlechtern und eine
Verstaatlichung unumgänglich machen
würden takuru morinaga takuru morinaga
ein Bekannter Wirtschaftswissenschaftler
in Tokio argumentierte eindränglich dass
der von der japanischen Zentralbank
inspirierte Vorschlag von takenaka nicht
viele Einheimische Nutznieser hätte
sondern stattdessen vor allem
US-amerikanischen geierfonds zugute käme
die auf den Aufkauf notleidender
Vermögenswerte spezialisiert
sind diese geierfonds waren mit dem
Problem konfrontiert dass trotz über
200.000 Konkursen nur wenige Unternehmen
die groß genug waren um für die
geiafonds von Interesse zu sein Bankrott
gingen W kimur als Kimura und Fukui ihre
Unterstützung für den Insolvenzplan
bekundeten leitete erstera ein privates
Unternehmen das bei der Verbriefung von
notleidenden Vermögenswerten berät und
letzterer war Berater der Wall Street
Investment Firma Goldman Sax einem der
größten Betreiber von gaiafonds
weltweit her fui sein Mentor her jeno
und sein Mentor Herr ma Cava sie ahnen
es das sind einige der Prinzen des Jen
um die es in dem Buch geht sie haben in
den 80er Jahren und auch in den 90er
Jahren immer wieder gesagt was ist das
Ziel der Geldpolitik es ist die
Wirtschaftsstruktur zu verändern und wie
stellt man das an nun man braucht eine
Krise und genau dafür haben sie
gesorgt Richard wir haben keine Zeit
mehr ich muss Sie leider unterbrechen
ich arbeite für eine der großen
stadtbanken ich war früher für die
Kreditvergabe an die japanische
Zentralbank zuständig während der
bubblea wurde uns von der japanischen
Zentralbank alle drei Monate mitgeteilt
um wie viel die Kredite erhöht werden
mussten die Zuteilung der window
guidance der japanischen Zentralbank war
ein
Befehl die Ursache der Blase war die
window guidance und sie wurde auf
Anweisung der japanischen Zentralbank
durchgeführt die Abteilung die bei der
japanischen Zentralbank für die Quoten
für die window guidance zuständig war
hieß Banking
Department und wer war der
Verantwortliche dafür der Mann an der
Spitze dieser bankabteilung während der
Blase von 86 bis 89 war toshihiko Fukui
Herr Fukui der derzeitige Gouverneur der
japanischen Zentralbank ist der Mann der
die Blase geschaffen
hat als FI Gouverneur der japanischen
Zentralbank wurde sagte er das starke
Wachstumsmodell zerstört wird baue ich
ein Modell auf das in die neue era
passt sie haben in jeder Hinsicht Erfolg
gehabt wenn man sich die Liste ihrer
Ziele anschaut haben sie alle diese
Ziele erreicht das Finanzministerium
zerstören es auflösen eine unabhängige
Aufsichtsbehörde einrichten die
Unabhängigkeit der japanischen
Zentralbank selbst durch eine Änderung
des japanischen zentralbankgesetzes
erreichen und tiefgreifende strukturelle
Veränderungen in der Wirtschaft
herbeiführen indem sie sich von der
Produktion auf Dienstleistungen
verlagern sich öffnen deregulieren
liberalisieren privatisieren all
das in den 1920er Jahren ähelte japans
Wirtschaft in vielerlei Hinsicht der
heutigen US-Wirtschaft mit hartem
Wettbewerb aggressiven Einstellungen und
Entlassungen Übernahmeschlachten
zwischen großen untern nemen wenigen
bürokratischen Kontrollen starken
Aktionären die hohe Dividenden forderten
und einer Unternehmensfinanzierung durch
die Märkte nicht durch die
Banken während der gesamten
Nachkriegszeit war japans Wirtschaft
jedoch das Gegenteil stark reguliert mit
Kartellen die den Wettbewerb
einschränkten Bankfinanzierung und
überkreuzbeteiligungen die die Macht der
Aktionäre einschränkten keine übernahmen
und ein eingefrorener Arbeitsmarkt mit
lebenslanger Beschäftigung und di
altersvergütung es wurde behauptet dass
Japan um die Rezession zu beenden und
die Leistung zu verbessern vom
wohlfahrtskapitalismus zurück zum
shareholderkapitalismus Wechseln müsse
es bleibt jedoch unklar warum ein Land
das einen beständigen und erheblichen
Handelsbilanzüberschuss erzielt hat sein
Wirtschaftssystem ändern muss um
wettbewerbsfähiger zu
sein
Japan war nicht die einzige
leistungsstarke Volkswirtschaft in Asien
die in den 1990er Jahren in die tiefste
Rezession seit der Großen Depression
geret97 ungen der südostasiatischen
Tigerstaaten keinen festen Wechselkurs
zum US-Dollar aufrechterhalten sie
brachen innerhalb eines Jahres um 60 bis
80%
ein die Ursachen für diesen Absturz
reichen bis in das Jahr 1993 zurück in
jenem Jahr führten die asiatischen
Tigerstaaten Südkorea Thailand und
Indonesien eine aggressive
lockerungspolitik im Kapitalverkehr und
internationale Bankdienstleistungen ein
die es dem Unternehmens und Bankensektor
ermöglichten großzügig Kredite im
Ausland aufzunehmen es war das erste Mal
in der Nachkriegszeit das Kreditnehmer
dies tun
konnten in reality in Wirklichkeit
bestand für die asiatischen Tigerstaaten
keine Notwendigkeit sich Geld im Ausland
zu leihen das gesamte für innländische
Investitionen erforderliche Geld konnte
im eigenen Land geschaffen werden der
Druck zur Liberalisierung der
Kapitalströme kam in der Tat von außen
seit Anfang der 1990er Jahre hatten der
IWF die
Welthandelsorganisation und das US
Finanzministerium Lobbyarbeit in diesen
Ländern betrieben um inländischen
Unternehmen die Kreditaufnahme im
Ausland zu ermöglichen sie
argumentierten dass die neoklassische
Wirtschaftslehre bewiesen habe dass
freie Märkte und freier Kapitalverkehr
das Wirtschaftswachstum
steigern
nach der Deregulierung der kapitalkunden
machten sich die Zentralbanken daran
unwiderstehliche Anreize für
innländische Unternehmen zu schaffen
Kredite im Ausland aufzunehmen sie
verteuerten die Kreditaufnahme in der
eigenen Landeswährung gegenüber der
Kreditaufnahme in
USDollar die inländischen Zinssätze
waren sie waren höher als die Zinssätze
des US-Dollars und der Wechselkurs war
praktisch
fix es waren die Regierung und die
Zentralbank die gesagt haben wir werden
den Wechselkurs
beibehalten das stimmt die Zentralbanken
Thailands und andere ostasiatischer
Länder widersetzten sich der
wechselkursanpassung und versuchten ein
Zeichen dafür zu setzen den Wechselkurs
schützen zu
wollen
[Musik]
die Zentralbanken betonten in ihren
öffentlichen Erklärungen dass sie feste
Wechselkurse zum US-Dollar beibehalten
würden sodass die Kreditnehmer nicht
befürchten mussten in ihrer
Landeswährung mehr zurückzuzahlen als
sie ursprünglich aufgenommen
hatten als ich in Thailand war ich war
auf einer ADB Mission als externer
Berater ging ich direkt zur Bank
voniland und fragte gibt es hier
irgendwelche informellen
Kreditrichtlinien sie waren überrascht
dass ich diese Frage stellte aufgrund
meines Studiums in Japan dachte ich dass
es vielleicht etwas ähnliches gäbe und
es war ein junger Mitarbeiter der sich
vielleicht der politischen Zusammenhänge
nicht bewusst war der sagte ja ja wir
haben so ein
kreditplanungsschema die Banken wurden
angewiesen die Kreditvergabe zu erhöhen
sie sahen sich jedoch mit einer
geringeren Kreditnachfrage aus den
produktiven Sektoren der Wirtschaft
konfrontiert da diese Unternehmen
Anreize erhalten hatten lieber Kredite
im Ausland aufzunehmen sie mussten daher
ihre kreditvergraab auf risikoreichere
Kreditnehmer
ausweiten die Importe begannen zu
schrumpfen weil die Zentralbanken
vereinbart hatten ihre Währungen an den
US-Dollar zu
binden die Volkswirtschaften wurden
weniger wettbewerbsfähig ihre
Leistungsbilanz blieb aufgrund der im
Ausland ausgegebenen Kredite die in der
zahlungsbilanzstatistik als Exporte
zählen
stabil als Spekulanten damit begannen
den thailändischen Bart den koreanischen
won und die indonesische Rupie zu
verkaufen reagierten die jeweiligen
Zentralbanken mit vergeblichen Versuchen
die Bindung aufrechtzuerhalten bis sie
praktisch ihre gesamten Devisenreserven
aufgebraucht hat
[Musik]
dies gab ausländischen Kreditgebern
reichlich Gelegenheit ihr Geld zu
überhöhten Wechselkursen
abzuziehen die Zentralbanken wussten
dass sie wenn den Ländern die
Devisenreserven ausgingen den IWF
Einschalten mussten um einen
Zahlungsausfall zu vermeiden und wenn
der IWF erst einmal da war wussten die
Zentralbanken was diese in Washington
ansäsige Institution verlangen würde
denn ihre Forderungen waren in solchen
Fällen in den vergangenen Jahrzehnten
immer die gleichen die Zentralbanken
sollten unabhängig
werden am 16 juli flog der thailändische
Finanzminister nach tok um Japan um ein
Rettungspaket zu
bitten damals verfügte Japan über die
visenreserven in Höhe von 213 Milliarden
USDollar mehr als die gesamten Mittel
des
man war bereit zu helfen aber Washington
stoppte die Initiative Japans jede
Lösung für die sich entwickelnde
Asienkrise musste von Washington über
den IWF
kommen nach zwei Monaten spekulativer
Angriffe hat die thailändische Regierung
den Bart
freigegeben
der Internationale Währungsfond hat den
angeschlagenen Volkswirtschaften von
Thailand Indonesien und Südkorea bisher
fast 120 Milliarden Dollar
zugesagt unmittelbar nach ihrer Ankunft
in den krisengeschüttelten Ländern
richteten die ewfteams Büros in den
Zentralbanken ein von wous sie regeln
Vorgaben die sich wie eine
kapitulationsforderung
anhörten
der IWF forderte eine Reihe von
Maßnahmen darunter die Einschränkung der
Kreditvergabe durch die Zentralbank und
die Banken umfangreicher
Gesetzesänderungen und eine drastische
Anhebung der
Zinssätze als die Zinssätze stiegen
konnten erste risikoreiche Kreditnehmer
ihre darle nicht mehr bedienen die
Bankensysteme Thailands Koreas und
Indonesiens die mit großen Mengen
uneinbringlicher Forderungen belastet
waren waren praktisch
selbst ansonsten gesunde Unternehmen
begannen unter der sich ausweitenden
Kreditklemme zu leiten die
Unternehmensinsolvenzen stiegen
sprunghaft an die Arbeitslosigkeit stieg
auf den höchsten Stand seit den 1930er
Jahren die Rolle des Fonds bei der
Rettung angeschlagener Länder ist heftig
umstritten einige haben den IWF sogar
beschuldigt die Wirtschaftskrise in
Asien zu verschärfen
selbst wenn Sie unsere Wirtschaft
untergraben müssen werden sie das tun
nur um zu beweisen dass Sie im Recht
sind diewf war keine große
Hilfe der IWF wusste genau welche Folgen
sein Vorgehen haben würde im Falle
Koreas wurden sogar detaillierte aber
nicht veröffentlichte Studien
durchgeführt in denen berechnet wurde
wie viele koreanische Unternehmen
bankrott gehen würden wenn die Zinssätze
um 5% Punkte
stiegen
das erste Abkommen des IWF mit Korea
verlangte eine Erhöhung der Zinssätze um
genau 5%
Punkte die Politik des IWF zielt
eindeutig nicht darauf ab einen
wirtschaftlichen Aufschwung in den
asiatischen Ländern zu erreichen sie
verfolgen eine ganz andere Agenda
nämlich die Veränderung der
wirtschaftlichen politischen und
sozialen Systeme in diesen Ländern und
wirklich die IWF Geschäfte verhindern
dass die betroffenen Länder wie Korea
und Thailand einen Aufschwung erleben
interessant sie sagen dass es die Krisen
verschlimmere und sie behaupten dass die
IWF eine heimliche Agenda habe diese
Agenda ist kein Geheimnis denn der IWF
verlangt ganz offen dass die Betroffenen
asiatischen Länder die Gesetze ändern
damit ausländische Interessenten alles
kaufen können von Banken bis zu Land und
in der Tat können die Bankensysteme laut
IWF Deal nur mit ausländischem Geld ihr
Kapital erhöhen dabei ist das gar nicht
notwendig denn solange diese Länder
Zentralbanken haben können Sie einfach
Geld drucken und die Bankensysteme
rekapitalisieren dafür braucht man kein
Geld aus dem Ausland es geht also
eindeutig darum Asien für ausländische
Interessenten zu
öffnen IWF verlangte dass in
Schwierigkeiten geratene Banken nicht
gerettet sondern geschlossen und als
notleidende aktiv billig verkauft werden
häufig an große
usinestmentbanken
eine gute Nachricht aus Thailand ist
dass sie einige große Vermögenswerte von
56 Finanzunternehmen versteigern werden
sollten ihrer Meinung nach einige der
Eigentümer der 56 Finanzunternehmen die
Möglichkeit haben ihre Vermögenswerte
zurückzukaufen in den meisten Fällen
wurde in den vom IWF diktierten
Absichtserklärungen ausdrücklich
festgelegt dass die Banken an
ausländische Investoren verkauft werden
mussten
und lassen Sie mich in dieser Hinsicht
betonen dass diese Reformprogramme der
Schlüssel der absolute Schlüssel zur
Wiederherstellung der finanziellen
Stabilität
sind zum ersten Mal überhaupt hat
Südkorea fünf Banken geschlossen und
damit einen wichtigen Schritt zur
Erfüllung des iwfmandats
getan die Zahl der Geschäftsbanken ist
zurückgegangen durch Schließungen
Fusionen und Übernahmen und ausländische
strategische Investoren mischen jetzt
mit was eine bemerkenswerte Veränderung
ist
[Musik]
in Asien waren staatlich organisierte
Rettungsaktionen zur Rettung maroder
Finanzinstitute untersagt doch als ein
Jahr später eine ähnliche Krise in
Amerika ausbrach reagierten dieselben
Institute
anders
the Conneticut based hedge fund longterm
Cap der in Conneticut ansässige
Hedgefond longterm Capital Management
der nur vermögende Privatanleger und
Institutionen als Kunden akzeptierte
hatte sein kundenkapital von 5
Milliarden Dollar um mehr als das
25fache gehebelt und sich dafür von den
Banken dieser Welt mehr als 100
Milliarden Dollar
geliehen
als ihre Verluste die Banken mit
runterzuziehen drohten die ihr Kredite
gewährt hatten und eine systemische
Bankenkrise drohte die das US
Finanzsystem und die US Wirtschaft
gefährden konnte organisierte die
Federal Reserve eine kartellähnliche
Rettungsaktion indem sie sich auf die
Wall Street und internationale Banken
stützte um Mittel beizusteuern mit denen
ein Zahlungsausfall vermieden werden
konnte sie haben Recht Washington und
new yorken zweierlei Maß zu messen kurz
nachdem sie allen asiatischen Ländern
gesagt hatten dass es keine
Rettungsaktionen für Finanzinstitutionen
geben würde wurde für longterm Capital
Management ein hedgephone New York der
fast pleite ging plötzlich eine
Rettungsaktion organisiert was im
Widerspruch zu dem standand was sie den
asiatischen Ländern gerade erst gesagt
hatten aber sie sagten dass keine
öffentlichen Gelder für LTCM verwendet
wurden aber das Treffen fand bekanntlich
innerhalb der Federal Reserve
statt
warum sollten die Vereinigten Staaten im
Namen des freien Marktes Forderungen an
fremde Nationen stellen wenn sie nicht
die Absicht haben dieselben Regeln
innerhalb ihrer eigenen Grenzen
durchzusetzen die Beispiele der
japanischen und der asiatischen Krise
zeigen wie Krisen konstruiert werden
können um die Umverteilung von
wirtschaftlichem Eigentum zu erleichtern
und rechtliche strukturelle und
politische Veränderungen
durchzusetzen today heute sind ähnliche
Ereignisse in der Eurozone zu
beobachten die Länder des
eurowährungsblocks haben ihr Recht auf
eine nationale Währung verloren und die
Macht an die Europäische Zentralbank
abgegeben bei mir hier im Studio ist
Richard Werner er ist Professor an der
Universität southhemton Richard war
Berater der japanischen Zentralbank und
des Finanzministeriums am Ende der
Babbel an der 90 Jahren was raten sie
der EZB die morgenag was würden Sie Ihr
sagen nun auch hier sollte sie sich mehr
auf das Kreditvolumen als auf die
Zinssätze konzentrieren die EZB muss aus
ihren Fehlern der Vergangenheit lernen
denn ich glaube sie hat die
Kreditschöpfung nicht sorgfältig genug
überwacht in Spanien und Irland hatten
wir unter der Aufsicht der EZB eine
massive Kreditausweitung der leitzenss
in der Eurozone ist natürlich überall
gleich aber das Volumen der Kredite ist
sehr unterschiedlich es gibt einen
einheitlichen Zinssatz für die gesamte
Eurozone aber 2002 wies die EZB die
Deutsche Bundesbank an ihre
Kreditschöpfung um den größten Betrag in
ihrer Geschichte zu reduzieren und sie
wies die irische Zentralbank an Geld zu
drucken als gäbe es kein
Morgen was wird nun also kommen gleicher
leidzins gleiches Wachstum nein
Rezession in Deutschland Aufschwung in
Irland was sagt Ihnen das welche
Variable
Kreditschöpfung 2004 hier stiegen unter
der Aufsicht der EZB die Bankkredite in
Irland Griechenland Portugal und Spanien
um über 20% pro Jahr an und die
mobilienpreise schossen in die Höhe als
die Bankkredite zurückgingen brachen die
mobilienpreise ein Bauträger gingen
pleite und die bankenysteme von Irland
Portugal Spanien und Griechenland wurden
zahlungsunfähig die EB hätte diese
Blasen verhindern können ebenso wie sie
die darauffolgenden Banken und
Wirtschaftskrisen hätte beenden können
doch sie weigerte sich dies zu tun bevor
nicht größere politische Zugeständnisse
gemacht wurden wie beispielsweise die
Übertragung der Steuer und
haushaltsbefugnisse von den einzelnen
souveränen Staaten auf die Europäische
Union sowohl in Spanien als auch in
Griechenland ist die
Jugendarbeitslosigkeit auf 50% gestiegen
sodass viele Jugendliche gezwungen sind
sich im Ausland Arbeit zu suchen
griechische Ärzte für deren Ausbildung
die griechischen Steuerzahler bezahlt
haben arbeiten jetzt in
Deutschland die Beratungen der
beschlussorgane der EZB sind geheim der
bloße Versuch einer Einflussnahme auf
die EZB etwa durch demokratische
Debatten und Diskussionen ist nach dem
Vertrag von Maastricht untersagt die EZB
ist eine internationale Organisation die
über den Gesetzen und Zuständigkeiten
der einzelnen Staaten steht ihre
leitenden Mitarbeiter tragen
Diplomatenpässe und die Akten und
Dokumente innerhalb der Europäischen
Zentralbank können von keiner
Polizeibehörde oder Staatsanwaltschaft
durchsucht oder beschlagnahmt
werden ECB die EZB ist unter Ökonomen
als eine der mächtigsten und
intransparentesten Zentralbanken der
Welt bekannt doch ihr ehemaliger
Präsident Jean-Claude tricher begegnete
diesem Problem mit der bloßen Behauptung
es gäbe kein
Problem die EZB ist eine der
transparentesten Zentralbanken der Welt
und hat dazu beigetragen den Stand der
Technik im zentralbankwesen in diesem
Bereich zu definieren behauptete
er Weltwirtschaftsforum Davos
Schweiz
mein Name ist Richard Werner ich bin
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler meine Frage
richtet sich an Herrn Trich die Frage
ist wo im Vertrag von Maastricht oder in
den EZB Statuten steht dass es die
Aufgabe der EZB ist Strukturreformen
oder eine andere politische Agenda zu
unterstützen ich habe sehr sehr deutlich
gesagt und wir haben immer wieder sehr
sehr deutlich gesagt dass wir in diesem
Bereich keine Verantwortung tragen wir
haben eine Meinung und wir sagen was wir
denken und wenn wir dadurch dazu
beitragen können den Menschen von
unserer Seite aus zu erklären dass es
ihnen besser gehen könnte dann würde das
vielleicht Europa dabei helfen mit der
Umsetzung von Strukturreformen zu
beginnen die so wichtig sind und darüber
gibt es einen Konsens einen sehr sehr
großen Konsens in diesem
punktagn very very very
[Musik]
L
die Europäische Kommission eine nicht
gewählte Interessensgruppe deren Zieles
ist Vereinigte Staaten von Europa mit
allen Merkmalen eines Einheitsstaates zu
erschaffen hat ein Interesse daran die
einzelnen Regierungen und den Einfluss
der demokratischen Parlamente Europas zu
[Musik]
schwächen wie sich herausstellte
standamen die Beweise für die
Unabhängigkeit der Zentralbanken auf die
sich der Vertrag von Maastricht stützte
aus einer einzigen Studie die von
niemand anderem als der Europäischen
Kommission selbst in Auftrag gegeben
worden
war die 1992 unter dem Titel ein Markt
eine Währung veröffentlichte Studie
behauptete zu beweisen dass die
Unabhängigkeit der Zentralbanken zu
einer niedrigen Inflation führt James
James Forer ein Wissenschaftler aus
Oxford hat inzwischen nachgewiesen dass
diese Studie manipuliert wurde um das
gewünschte Ergebnis zu
erreichen
die Geschichte die uns von den
Zentralbanken erzählt wird ist
widersprüchlich und es gibt Beweise
dafür dass die Zentralbanken anders
arbeiten als uns glauben machen
wollen auf der ganzen Welt haben die
Zentralbanken bedeutende aber wenig
bekannte Befugnisse oft unabhängig nicht
rechenschaftspflichtig und
undurchsichtig agieren Zentralbanken im
Verborgenen doch ihr Handeln betrifft
uns
alle
[Musik]
die Zentralbanken in fast allen Ländern
der Welt und der IWF hat einiges dazu
beigetragen sind völlig unabhängig
geworden und praktisch keiner
demokratischen Institution gegenüber
rechenschaftspflichtig selbst die
Rechenschaftspflicht gegenüber dem
Parlament ist in der Regel gering und in
der Praxis
bedeutungslos ob es sich um die
japanische Zentralbank die Federal
Reserve die Bank of England oder die
Europäische Zentralbank handelt
Beispiele für der Zentralbanken gibt es
viele in den Vereinigten Staaten wurden
die Banken in den 1920er Jahren ermutigt
Geld zu schaffen und es an Spekulanten
zu geben die daraus resultierende
Depression überzeugte die
freiheitsliebenden Amerikaner davon dass
ein dezentralisiertes fedderales System
ohne starke nationale Kontrolle nicht
funktionieren
[Musik]
konnte in den 1990er Jahren wurden die
Japaner davon überzeugt dass ihr
Wirtschaftssystem das beträchtlichen
Wohlstand und Gleichheit gebracht hatte
in ein sogenanntes System der freien
Marktwirtschaft umgeandelt werden
müsse Japans Transformation war noch
nicht vollständig abgeschlossen da
schlugen die Zentralbanker erneut zu und
zwar mit einem vom IWF angeführten
Überfall auf die Volkswirtschaften der
asiatischen
Tigerstaaten die gegenwärtige
europäische Schuldenkrise ist ein
weiteres Beispiel für die Täuschung der
Zentralbanken
einen öffentlichen Konsens für die
Notwendigkeit von Strukturreformen zu
schaffen inem man absichtlich eine
Rezession herbeiführt und sie dann
unnötig verlängert stellt einen
Machtmissbrauch
da wollen die Bürger wirklich auf so
kostspielige und unehrliche Weise
manipuliert
werden
ร
[Musik]
ครับ nach dem Buch Prinzen desen von
Professor Richard
Werner
[Musik]